it's Corbin was it purely brexit or did
you take the party too far to the left
we fought a great campaign with a
manifesto of hope and that hope is
eternal in our party but was it him who
stifled any hope of labour winning this
election this morning outside the
leaders house the Corbin bubble burst
he'll stand down probably replaced by
the spring so is this the end of his
socialist dream do you think that Corbin
ISM is dead it's not it's not Corbin ISM
there is no such thing as Corbin ISM
there is socialism there is social
justice there are radical manifestos all
of which are there but are there also
unelectable no I don't think they are
unelectable at all I think the issue
that dominated this election ultimately
was brexit and those who support Jeremy
Corbyn say a defeat due to brexit
doesn't mean his vision was wrong look
at 2017 we gained 3 million extra votes
we had a similar manifesto the same
leader the same Shadow Chancellor the
same show the Home Secretary and now two
years later we had an electoral defeat
the only thing that seems to change in
those two years has been the issue of
briggsie but this result for labour was
catastrophic the lowest number of seats
since 1935 losing in their heart lands
in seats like Sedgefield that used to be
held by Tony Blair with a majority of
25,000 and MPs and unsuccessful
candidates so you can't simply blame
this defeat on brexit the man who lost
Sedgefield after representing it for 12
years blames the leader but every one
person that our sport to about brexit on
the doorstep they'd be five people who
raised during me Corbin's
leadership and i think that is the main
cause of why so many of my colleagues
lost their seats we had a confetti of
promises that on the doorstep nobody
believed we could deliver it was an
unbelievable agenda he was not trusted
on national security center left-leaning
MPs say this proves the far left project
has failed they had the leader they
wanted they had the manifesto they
wanted
they had the national executive they
wanted the brexit policy they wanted the
political staff and strategy that they
wanted and this is the consequence so
they need to own their failure but labor
centrists fear that Corbin's allies have
taken hold of the party and will be hard
to shift people like Len McCluskey who
is the architect of our misfortune above
all else who has helped Corbin to take
complete control of all the Labour
Party's apparatus what we can't have
is Corbin mark to robin mark to will
mean that labor will fall further into
the abyss there'll be a fight now
continuity Corbin ISM versus the back to
Blair center left history might find his
time as Labour leader had a profound
effect on British politics even though
he exits centre stage without becoming
Prime Minister
Jason Farrell Sky News